WASHINGTON.
YOU ARE LIVE IN THE CNN
NEWSROOM.
>> RUSSIA'S REREVENGE AND
UKRAINIAN CIVILIANS PAY THE
PRIDE.
OVERNIGHT THEY RAIN DOWN ON
ZAPORIZHZHIA IN SOUTHEASTERN
UKRAINE.
AT LEAST 13 PEOPLE ARE DEAD.
DOZENS ARE HOSPITALIZED.
MORE THAN 200 RESCUERS HAVE BEEN
COMBING THROUGH THE RUBBLE,
LOOKING FOR SURVIVORS AND MORE
VICTIMS.
THE RUSSIAN ATTACK ON THIS
ENABLED COMES HOURS AFTER A
TRUCK BOMB ON THE BRIDGE.
THAT'S CREATED A HUGE
BOTTLENECK, CHOKING A CRITICAL
SUPPLY ROUTE FOR PEOPLEN'S WEAR.
THESE NEW SATELLITE IMAGING SHOW
THE DAMAGE FROM ABOVE.
DESPITE THAT, RUSSIA SAYS IT'S
RESUMING SOME CAR AND TRAIN
SERVICE.
FRED PLEITGEN IS IN KYIV WITH
THE LATEST.
>> Reporter: CERTAINLY SOME
STRIKES THERE IN ZAPORIZHZHIA.
SOME BUILDINGS HAVE BEEN -- OF
COURSE, SCORES OF PEOPLE WERE
KILLED AND WOUNDED IN THOSE
ATTACKS.
IF WE LOOK BACK OVER THE PAST
COUPLE DAYS, THAT'S NOT THE
FIRST TIME ZAPORIZHZHIA HAS BEEN
HIT.
HERE'S WHAT WE'RE LEARNING.
SATELLITE IMAGES TAKEN SHORTLY
AFTER THE EXPLOSION SHOW THE
BRIDGE IN FLAMES.
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATORS CONTINUE
TO SAY THE BLAST WAS CAUSED WHEN
A TRUCK EXPLODED, CAUSING PART
OF THE ROADWAY TO COLLAPSE AND
SEVERAL TRAIN CARS TO ALSO BLOW
UP.
WHILE MOSCOW SAYS THE RAIL LINE
IS BACK UP AND RUNNING, FEW CARS
CAN PASS WHAT IS LEFT OF THE
AUTOMOBILE BRIDGE, CAUSING
MASSIVE TRAFFIC DISRUPTION.
>> IF THERE'S GOOD WEATHER, WE
COULD CROSS THE FERRY.
IT'S A MAJOR SYMBOLIC AND
STRATEGIC BLOW TO RUSSIAN
PRESIDENT PUTIN'S WAR ON
UKRAINE.
MOSCOW BLAMING UKRAINE FOR THE
ATTACK, BUT SO FAR, NO CLAIM OF
RESPONSIBILITY.
>> TODAY WAS A GOOD AND MOSTLY
SUNNY DAY IN OUR COUNTRY.
OVER MOST OF THE TERRITORY, IT
WAS ABOUT 20 DEGREES CELSIUS AND
SUNNY.
UNFORTUNATELY IT WAS CLOUD
COUNTER IN CRIMEA, THOUGH STILL
WARM.
HOWEVER THE CLOUDS ARE,
UKRAINIANS KNOW WHAT TO DO.
THEY KNOW OUR FUTURE IS SUNNY.
>> Reporter: UKRAINIANS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY REJOICED IN THE
NEWS.
>> Translator: NOBODY KNOWS, BUT
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
EVERYONE WAITED, IT PROVED WE
EVEN DECIDED TO TAKE A WALK.
>> Translator: THE NEWS IS GOOD.
WE WAITED, WAITED AND HAPPENED.
HITTING THE MAJOR CITY AFTER A
STRING OF SETBACKS, THE RUSSIANS
ALSO THE RUSSIAN DEFENSE
MINISTER HAS APPOINTED GENERAL
SERGEI AS COMMANDER THE COMBINED
GROUP OF TROOPS.
EVEN AS MOSCOW USS BOTH ROAD AND
RAIL TRAFFIC WAS BACK UP OVER
THE CRIMEAN BRIDGE,IST ONLY A
TRICKLE OF WHAT WE -- MAY HAVE
BEEN THIS ANOTHER BOTTLENECK
IMPEDING THE WAR EFFORT IN
UKRAINE.
WE'VE HEARD FROM THE CREME LING
THAT PUTIN IS GOING TO SHARE A
MEETING OF THE RUSSIAN COUNCIL.
WE DO KNOW THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN
HAS ALREADY SIGNED A DECREE FOR
INCREASE THE SECURITY OF THE
BRIDGE, BECAUSE IT'S AN
IMPORTANT LOGISTICS ROUTE FOR
RUSSIA'S MILITARY SO THERE'S A
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASPECT THIS.
LET'S DRILL DOWN A BIT.
YOU HAVE UKRAINE PUBLICLY
CELEBRATING, BUT IT HASN'T
CLAIMED RESPONSIBILITY.
HOW SIGNIFICANT WAS THE
TARGETING OF THIS BRIDGE?
>> THIS WAS USUALLY SIGNIFICANT.
THIS BRIDGE CONNECTS EVERYTHING
HERE.
THIS IS THE LOWER AREA OF
CRIMEA.
THIS IS ALREADY RUSSIAN
TERRITORY.
THE BRIDGE IS RIGHT WITHIN THE
CIRCLE RIGHT HIRE.
SO THIS BRIDGE IS REALLY A
MASTER WORK OF ENGINEERING, AND
FOR THAT REASONS IT CONNECTIONS
RUSSIA AND CRIMEA, AND ALLOWS
FOR --, THAT MAKES THEM MORE
BETTER TO MOVE THE PRODUCTS,
WEAPONS, TROOPS INTO A WARFRONT
WITH THAT GONE, IT BECOMES MUCH
MORE DIFFICULT.
>> YEAH, I MENTIONED THERE'S A
PSYCHOLOGICAL ELEMENT TO THIS.
WILL PUTIN SEE THIS AS A DIRECT
ATTACK ON HIM AND HIS
GOVERNMENT?
>> WELL, YES.
IN 2018, HE ACTUALLY OPENED THIS
BRIDGE.
THAT'S HIM WALKING TO THE BRIDGE
TO DRIVE THIS TRUCK ON THIS
BRIDGE.
THE REASON HE DID THIS IS HE WAS
SO PROUD OF THIS BRIDGES IT'S
FILLY ANNEXING RUSSIA INTO
CRIMEA.
THAT'S WHY HE DID IT.
WE SAW RUSSIA APPARENTLY
RETALIATE IN ZAPORIZHZHIA.
>> WE EXPECT MORE.
ZAPORIZHZHIA IS RIGHT HERE.
IT'S ACTUALLY IN UKRAINIAN
HANDS.
POTENTIALLY THEY MAY TRY TO DO
THINGS IN THIS AREA AS WELL.
EVEN REMOTELY POSSIBLE, THERE'S
A POSSIBILITY FOR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT TO HAPPEN.
>> IT IS REMARKABLE.
THEY HAVE -- WHAT DOES THAT DO
TACTICALLY FOR THEM?
DOES.
>> HERE IS THE DNIEPER RIVER,
HERE IS THE TOWN, AND UKRAINIANS
HAVE TAKEN THIS AND THIS AREA.
WHAT THE UCRANNANCE CAN DO.
IF THEY CUT THE RUSSIANS OFF
FROM THIS AREA, THAT MEANS THESE
TROOPS WILL BE ENCIRCLED AND
POTENTIAL LOST TO THE WAR
EFFORT.
>> THERE ARE SOME EXPERTS THAT
SAY IT'S LOSING THE TRUST, THE
SUPPORT OF THE FORMER SOVIET
REPUBLIC.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
EACH ONE OF THEM HAS REALLY
MOVED IN ITS OWN WAY TO BUILD A
ROAD AND RAILROAD THROUGH THEIR
TERRITORIES TO AVOID RUSSIA.
THAT WAS SOMETHING AS PART OF
THE BELT-AND-ROAD INITIATIVE.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT THE CHINESE
HAVE AVOIDED BUT BECAUSE THE
RUSSIANS ARE LOSING CONTROL OVER
THESE AREAS.
>> THAT'S REALLY TELLING, VERY
INTERESTING.
THANK YOU.
>> YOU BET.
>>> THERE WAS A CONVERSATION
TODAY, SO LET'S GO TO THE WHITE
HOUSE, AND CNN'S ARLETTE SAENZ,
WHAT ARE YOU LEARNING?
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN IS SPENDING
THE WEEKEND AT HIS HOME, WHERE
HE SPOKE WITH THE GERMAN
CHANCELLOR OVER THE PHONE.
THE TWO MEN TALKED ABOUT IT AS
WELL, AS RECENT DEVELOPMENTS,
ACCORDING TO THE WHITE HOUSE,
BUT THAT CALL COMES AS THE
PRESIDENT'S RECENT COMMENTS
ABOUT THE PROSPECTS OF NUCLEAR
ARM EMBEDDING REMAIN IN THE
SPOTLIGHT FORM JOHN KIRBY THIS
MORNING SAID THERE'S NO IMMINENT
THREAT RIGHT NOW OF RUSSIA USES
NUCLEAR WEAPONS, BUT THE
PRESIDENT'S COMMENTS SIMPLY
SPEAK TO THE GRAVITY WITH WHICH
THEY'RE VIEWING THE SITUATION.
>> IT WAS NOT BASED ON NEW
INTELLIGENCE OR NEW INDICATIONS
THAT MR. PUTIN HAS MADE A
DECISION TO USE NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
QUITE FRANKLY WE DON'T HAVE
ANY -- THE PRESIDENT WAS
REFLECTING THAT THE STAKES ARE
HIGH RIGHT NOW, GEFFEN WHAT'S
GOING ON ON THE BATTLEFIELD IN
UKRAINE AND GEFFEN THE VERY
IRRESPONSIBLE AND RECKLESS
CONDUCTS MADE BY VLADIMIR PUTIN
2349 LAST FEW DAYS.
HE ALSO SAID WE'RE NOT GOING TO
BE INTIMIDATED BY THIS.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT AND SECURITY
ASSISTANCE TO UKRAINE AS IS
NECESSARY.
>> Reporter: EARLIER THIS WEEK
PRESIDENT BIDEN ALSO USED IN
THIS FUND-RAISER WHETHER THERE'S
AN OFF-RAMP FOR PUTIN TO AVOID
USING NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
KIRBY WAS ASKED ABOUT THAT.
HE SAID HE DID NOT ELABORATE ON
ANY OFFENSES THAT THE U.S. MIGHT
BE CONSIDERING, BUT IT'S
ULTIMATELY UP